vor drei vier Wochen hat alles damit
begonnen dass euer Arbeitgeber gesagt
hat dass er euch gar nichts zahlen wird
dann hat er 5000 Euro angeboten also 80
Euro pro Fahrer
Edwina Thema wurde von den
Gewerkschaften zum Verhandlungsführer
ernannt immer wieder telefoniert der
Niederländer mit dem polnischen
Arbeitgeber der Fahrer aus Georgien und
Usbekistan die seit Monaten kein Geld
bekommen haben ihre rund 60 LKWs liegen
seit vier Wochen hier in der Raststätte
Gräfenhausen still
wir sind doch nur nach Europa gekommen
um Geld zu verdienen damit wir unsere
Familien in der Heimat unterstützen
können jetzt werden wir so respektlos
behandelt wir sind alle sehr sauer
nach dem Gesetz müssten wir nach zwei
Wochen die wir hier ununterbrochen
unterwegs sind zwei Tage frei bekommen
und dann auch in einem Hotel schlafen
das alles ist nie passiert und wir
arbeiten täglich bis zu 15 Stunden
auch der 56-Jährige
harte Arbeit immer wieder Überstunden
und dann noch nicht einmal Geld dafür
das habe das fast zum Überlaufen
gebracht der Familienvater sagt dass er
seit 3 Monaten nicht bezahlt wurde
ich bin seit 11 Monaten ununterbrochen
auf der Straße ich esse und schlafe in
meinem Lastwagen das ist mein Leben
zu Hause in Georgien hat Kara seine Frau
zwei Kinder und vier Enkelkinder viele
Menschen die von dem Geld dass er in
Europa verdient abhängig sind auf rund
zwei Quadratmetern lebt er seit fast
einem Jahr das Essen in der Raststätte
kann er sich meistens nicht leisten
als ich Anfang letzten Jahres mit dieser
Arbeit begannen teilte der Chef mir
erstmal mit dass er künftig für die
Sonntage nicht mehr zahlen würde
im ersten Monat haben wir auch kein Geld
bekommen es hieß dass wir das Geld
nachträglich erhalten nachdem wir ein
Jahr gearbeitet haben
wie alle Fahrer hier ist Karcher sehr
dankbar für die große Solidarität die
sie seit Wochen in Gräfenhausen erleben
Ingrid von der katholischen
Betriebsseelsorge kommt regelmäßig
hierher und kommuniziert mit den Fahrern
dank des Google Übersetzers
Gott sei Dank es geht uns allen gut in
Deutschland in Europa und neben uns und
dass wir nicht mehr Angst haben
denn was am Karfreitag passierte hat
nicht nur die Fahrer schockiert ein
Panzerwagen mit Sicherheitsleuten kommt
an der Raststätte an
beauftragt vom polnischen Arbeitgeber
Masur der auch dabei war und die Aktion
von einem rechten polnischen Sender
begleiten
der Spediteur will seine Lastwagen mit
der Ware zurück
[Applaus]
seine Sicherheitsleute versuchen mit
Gewalt die Fahrer aus ihren Kabinen zu
zerren
die Polizei greift ein und kann das
verhindern ein Vorfall der auch beim
zuständigen Bürgermeister für Entsetzen
gesorgt hat dass das wirklich so wie in
einem schlechten Film dann auch hier
vorkommt bis bei uns eine völlig
unvorstellbare Situation und wir sind
wirklich heilfroh dass wir auch dafür
Sorge tragen könnten das hier auch nicht
schlimmeres passiert wird dass keiner
verletzt wurde und mittlerweile ja auch
der Spediteur offensichtlich eingelenkt
hat und ein Teil der Gehälter zumindest
im ersten Schritt bezahlt hat aber mehr
Geld wird es nicht geben sagt Spediteur
mal so im ZDF Interview und rechtfertigt
seine Aktion
Song
Contest Anzeigen gegen mich es heißt ich
hätte die wahre gestohlen im Vertrag
steht dass das Geld erst eineinhalb
Monate später gezahlt wird die
Arbeitnehmer haben dem zugestimmt und
jetzt kommt Herr artema von der
Gewerkschaft und sagt dass ich Ihnen
insgesamt rund
97.000 Euro Schulden würde
der Spediteur ist mit seinen Leuten
immer in telefonisch und Kontakt wenn in
diesen Wochen in grevenhausen verhandelt
wird es gehe um mehr als eineinhalb
Monate die nicht gezahlt worden sein
sagt Edwin ein Thema es sei bezeichnend
dass die Firma keine Dokumente vorliege
alle Unterlagen das wird natürlich
richtig überprüfen können das wollte die
Firma nicht so das sind Geschäftsmodelle
best of intersparent intransporte
Praktikum wo fahre wirklich zu schauen
economisch Gefängnis sind mehr als 60
Fahrer streiken in Gräfenhausen für ihre
Rechte und erleben auch die Solidarität
deutscher Lkw-Fahrer
jürgenius hat auf seinem Weg nach
Heidelberg Snacks vorbeigebracht
ich hoffe das hat bald ein Ende es gibt
ja tausende von denen und auch dieses
Paar ist zur Raststätte gekommen um sich
um das leibliche Wohl der Fahrer zu
kümmern
[Gelächter]
zur Aktion hier auf dem Parkplatz ist
bestimmt schwierig das Essen zubereiten
und es ist nur eine Kleinigkeit
für die die Streikenden sehr dankbar
sind keiner weiß wie lange sie noch hier
sind
sie wollen ihren Streik erst beenden
wenn alle Fahrer ihr Geld erhalten haben
[Musik]